-Welcome, welcome,
welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
You're here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I went to --
I saw Harry Styles last night.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We were all there together.
We all went together as a group.
I was just thinking -- So, I
go, and it was unbelievable.
I got great seats
and everything like that.
It was very nice of Harry
and all that stuff.
So, I went.
And it's just hard to
look cool when you're --
When you're kind of --
When you're my age
at a Harry Styles concert.
And you're in the front row,
and people are looking at you
and stuff like that.
So, like -- So, he's playing
and he's awesome.
It was a great show, by the way.
Go see it. And he's good.
And so, I go,
"Alright, I can get into this."
So, I'm like that, you know?
I'm like...
♪♪
And then I'm like,
"Oh, this is really lame."
I go, "This is worse than
I normally dance."
So I go,
"I'm not going to really --"
So, then I started going like
this for a while.
And then I was like,
"That's even weirder.
I don't know what's happening."
Then I go,
maybe clapping was good.
So, I'm like -- So, give me...
♪♪
Then I'm like,
"This is too much clapping."
I was clapping too fast.
I was like...
Like double-clapping.
Alright, no clap.
Then I go with this.
-Oh!
-That's just creepy.
-Not with that.
-You can't do that.
And then, at that point, I go,
"I'm already a meme."
-Right. Might as well enjoy it.
-I'm just going to have fun.
And I was like, "Yeah!"
♪ Late night ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
I'm in a good mood.
We got blood orange here,
tonight.
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's right. They opened up.
They were fantastic.
Also, guys, today is the --
officially the first day
of fall.
Come on!
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Come on, fall.
-That's why I'm in a good mood.
Everyone is talking about this.
Last night,
former president Trump
was interviewed by Sean Hannity
on Fox News.
And when Hannity
brought up Trump's claim
that he declassified the
documents found at Mar-a-Lago,
Trump gave a very
interesting explanation.
Take a look at this.
-Is there a process?
What was your process
to declassify?
-There doesn't have to be
a process, as I understand it.
You know, there's different --
People say different things.
But, as I understand,
there doesn't have to be --
If you're the
President of the United States,
you can declassify just by
saying, "It's declassified,"
even by thinking about it.
-Hannity was like,
"Oh, I get it.
You're going to plead insanity.
Okay, now it's making sense."
Meanwhile, Ron DeSantis
was watching at home going,
"Well, I guess
we've got to start
printing those campaign posters.
Here we go."
I felt like he was this close to
using the word "abracadabra."
Did you --
When Trump was talking.
Trump also suggested
a pretty interesting theory
on why the FBI searched
his house in the first place.
Listen to this.
-Because of what they did,
the severity of the FBI
coming and raiding Mar-a-Lago,
were they looking for the
Hillary Clinton e-mails
that were deleted?
But they are around someplace.
Were they looking for the --
-Wait, wait.
You're not saying you had it.
-No, no.
They may be saying --
They may have thought
that it was in there.
-At that point, even QAnon
people were like,
"Okay, that conspiracy seems
a little nuts.
That's a little much for us."
You've got to give Trump
credit, though.
He knows how to say
something so crazy
that it actually makes
the last crazy thing he said
seem normal.
You know, right?
You know what I'm saying?
Trump had a lot to say about
the search of Mar-a-Lago,
including something
the FBI took from him.
Watch this.
-They took a lot.
I think they took my will.
I found out yesterday.
I said, "Where is it?"
-Am I in it?
-I think they took my will.
That could cause
a lot of problems.
-I know.
-The FBI was like, "Oh,
you mean the piece of paper
with the Sharpie treasure map?
Yeah, we did --"
A minute later,
Melania handed it back
and was like, "Sorry,
I was just checking something.
"We're all good."
Switching gears,
tonight on Amazon,
there was another
Thursday night football game.
And, apparently, Amazon -- Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Apparently, Amazon has a policy
not to show ads for alcohol,
which means there are no
beer commercials
during their football games.
Yeah. I don't know why
Amazon does that,
because drunk people
ordering stuff
on Amazon is
90% of their business.
Speaking of football,
there's so many games
to keep up with this weekend,
so I wanted to
take a moment to look at
this week's big matches
and take some picks.
It's time for "Tonight Show
Weekend Football Lock Box."
-♪ "Tonight Show Weekend
Football Lock Box" ♪
♪ "Tonight Show Weekend
-You're in the Lock Box.
Let's kick it off.
First up,
Jaguars versus Chargers.
I bought six
iPhone chargers this year
and zero jaguars.
Why? Because Chargers get lost
and Jags get locked.
Bills versus Dolphins.
Who likes bills?
Always coming in the mail, being
all like, "Where's my money?"
For the last time, I don't know.
Call it canned tuna,
because this one's all Dolphins.
Lock it.
Eagles versus Commanders.
Both proud, both symbols of
America, both bald.
But commanders can't lay eggs,
so advantage Eagles.
From the City of Brotherly Lock.
♪ B-B-B-Bengals and the Jets ♪
Elton John may be known to rock,
but Cincinnati's
the one brewing up a big batch
of chili and spaghetti
in a lock pot.
49ers versus Broncos.
It's the city by the bay against
the horse that eats the hay.
49ers pan for gold,
horses get locked in pens.
Easy Denver lock.
And, finally,
Lions versus Vikings.
For ball spiking,
lineman striking, fan sacking,
you just can't beat
the Detroit Lions.
Motor City lock.
That's all for
this week's Lock Box.
Happy watching.
I'll see you
in the DraftKings subreddit.
-♪ "Tonight Show Weekend
Football Lock Box" ♪
♪ "Tonight Show Weekend
-Some entertainment news.
A new "Star Wars" show, "Andor,"
just came out on Disney+.
It's getting great reviews.
And I saw that the show
introduces a new droid character
named B2EMO.
Can we take a look at B2EMO?
Honestly, he doesn't really
look that emo.
Can we see some clips of him
from the show?
-It's not a phase.
It's who I am.
Security confiscated
my wallet chain
at the My Chemical Romance show.
They're not cigarettes,
Dad, they're cloves.
And I'm 18, so leave me alone.
Has anyone seen my
"Nightmare Before Christmas"
beanie?
Just pick me up
at the mall at 10:00
and please don't embarrass me.
This whole star system
is bull[bleep]
-Oh, my God.
That was interesting.
Now I get it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
-I get it.
Some more entertainment news.
Tomorrow, "Avatar"
will be re-released in theaters
all across the country.
The movie originally
came out in 2009.
That was a long time ago.
Higgins, do you remember
where you were when you --
back in 2009,
when you first saw "Avatar"?
-Oh, yeah, of course.
I was dancing to "Boom Boom Pow"
by the Black Eyed Peas...
-Uh-huh.
-...when my friend, the Octomom,
texted me the "Avatar" trailer
on my BlackBerry Storm.
And as a thank-you,
I poked her on Facebook.
-Oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yo, I still remember
where I was
when I found out about "Avatar."
I was hanging out with my BFFs,
Taylor Lautner and Susan Boyle.
And we were
ghost-riding the whip
when Susan starts telling me
how good "Avatar" is.
So, I told her, "Susan Boyle,
I'mma let you finish,
but 'Sisterhood of
the Traveling Pants 2'
is the best movie of the year."
-Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
You want to know where I was
when I first heard about
"Avatar"?
I was doing a flash mob with
Snooki, JWoww,
and The Situation's cousin,
The Circumstance.
And when we realized
we all forgot to water
our FarmVille crops,
so we drove to my place
in my Nissan Cube
while blasting
the "Glee" soundtrack,
because we're big Gleeks.
And I heard an ad
for "Avatar" on the radio
while Snooki was asking me if I
was Team Edward or Team Jacob.
-Man, 2009 was a different time.
-2009?
Mine was from this morning.
-Hey, guys, I read that
battery-powered planes
are gaining traction
among major airlines.
They're set to be
in the air by 2028.
Yeah, battery-powered planes.
Actually, they've been
around for a while.
In fact, Spirit's entire fleet
runs on four AAA batteries.
It's true.
I heard about
a woman in Washington
who allegedly stole a car
and didn't have
a great getaway plan.
Check this out.
-If you plan to steal a car,
don't drive into
freshly poured concrete.
Lakewood police say
the person who tried to
make it out with this
Mini Cooper did just that.
They got out and tried to run
but were arrested anyway.
Police say the driver was
holding a bottle of whiskey
at the time.
-Yeah, you didn't need to
tell us that last part.
We assumed. Guys, get this.
Under a new law in California,
employers will
soon be banned from screening
employees for marijuana.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. That's right.
Employers will no longer be able
to drug-test people.
But if you ask me, they're still
trying to find ways around it.
Here are some of the questions
that they're asking
on the job application.
First up, it says...
You know what I'm saying?
Next up, it says...
-Okay.
-So I'm thinking...
After that, it says...
Next, it asks...
-Whoa!
-And, finally, it asks...
-Just interesting.
I'm just saying, they're tough.
Guys, did you see this?
Residents of Salt Lake City
have reported
hearing strange music
coming from the sewers.
Yeah, strange music,
as opposed to
the totally normal music usually
heard coming from the sewers.
Finally, a wedding reception
in New Jersey
had to be relocated
after the floor caved in
while people were dancing.
People showed up at the E.R.
like, "Hi.
I'm here for the
Freedman wedding."
Yeah. I'm pretty sure it's the
first wedding with
an open bar and an open floor.
We have a great show.